our people like dif different stuff and
drag is a different thing to parody but
it's also a loving celebration it's not
cruel it's not trying to victimize
people it's not trying to exclude people
it's like this is crazy crew t-shirts
and that is the reality of life
let the inaugural RuPaul's Drag Khan
begin hi I'm Alexis Garcia with recent
TV here in Los Angeles at the first-ever
Drac invention in her Surrey I'm a big
fan of RuPaul's Drag Race the reality
competition show in search of America's
next drag superstar and it's become a
pop culture phenomenon watched by
millions around the world we came to the
convention to talk to some of the stars
of the show to find out why drag is
finding an audience with mainstream
America what drag is is a celebration of
the fact that each and every one of us
is different but rather than something
that divides us and makes us unhappy and
victimizes us actually it's cause for
celebration drag as an art its
creativity its inspiration its happiness
this drama it's like everything thrown
it's like a big pot pie I'm the chicken
when people ask me what a drag mean to
me I say it means total liberation you
know and its freedom of expression drag
can be liberating but what you may not
know is that this once marginalized art
form is a great example of a
self-reliant community Queens have their
own language as in all tea all shade
hunty leaders good luck and five six
seven eight don't get up and lean on
each other for support and while dudes
dressing up in heels can be taboo behind
all the makeup and glitter is a group of
fierce and resilient people you know
we're dawning in the Age of Aquarius
honey it's time for people to open their
eyes and realize you know live and let
live and I think that people attached to
this because it's something tangible
that they can you know not only watch
every day but then now they can come to
you know drag con and meet us in person
and really see what it's like to you
know be in this atmosphere and a part of
that you know back in the you know
seventies and eighties when I was
growing up I had no good examples of you
know being myself I had to hide and be
this man that everybody expected me to
be
and you know drag allows me now to
express a side of myself that you know
I've always wanted to express and
talking about the popularity I mean do
you think it's changing attitudes or do
you think I think a lot of it has to do
with just RuPaul and just how hard he
works what do you attribute that to I
attribute so much of this too rupal
singular genius and from the very first
time that Randy and I saw RuPaul in
nineteen hundred and eighty-two Randy
and I turn to each other it said this
[ __ ] a star and it was just
really a question of waiting for the
rest of the world to catch up drag race
has definitely helped with getting this
a word mainstream now and people look at
us if we're enjoyment and a smile we
make instead of people giving us dirty
looks and glares people like objects I
want a picture with a drag queen no
matter who you are you know the
influence that drag race has had on
mainstream society has been very
impactful and very very useful in
healing homes and broken homes and
helping parents understand their their
gay child and it's been bringing
families actually together so it's been
wonderful drag race Andrews stand for
something different which is including
people supporting people lifting people
up celebrating your difference loving
the freak in you rather than trying to
shove it back in the closet what's the
point in that exactly let your freak
flag fire exactly let your freak flag
fly and a man can I get in a me
if you can't love yourself how in the
hell you're gonna love somebody else say
you